let's jump over into that first story we
got this one from the independent
jane's revenge group appears to threaten
violence if supreme court overturns roe
oh a flyer is calling for a knight of
rage i gotta put anonymite in washington
dc when the supreme court decision on
roe is handed down
i chose this source the independent
because they're like left-leaning and i
think it's funny that they're saying it
appears they're threatening violence
when they're outright saying you told us
you would riot
the militant abortion rights
organization change revenge appears to
be calling for a night of rage
in the nation's capital should the
supreme court as is expected overturn
roe v wade later this month this is the
organization that's already taken credit
for the vandalism and i'm not sure
uh did they did they take credit for the
fire bombings seamus let me look up that
let me let me look that up so we've had
now what it's like 20 plus either
pro-life politicians or pregnancy
centers get vandalized windows smashed
out and some were firebound more than
one
this is the organization that's taking
credit for some of these acts of terror
they're threatening war
you combine that with
the uh showing up in front of the
supreme court justices homes you combine
that with the trying to take the life of
a sitting supreme court justice and i
mean we've just been watching extreme
violence over the past several years and
i gotta say
it really does feel like things are
crazier than they've been in a very long
time yeah 100 i completely agree i think
that the the worst part about this is
it doesn't work
so all it does is dig people deeper into
their own someone doesn't see that and
go oh they're firebombing well you know
what now i'm on your side no nobody does
that it just creates more violence it
dehumanizes the other it validates
violence as a as a way of feeling good
about your issue if you're really upset
about this and i get if you are i
understand that that viewpoint then
simply go to your state and have your
state make sure that you can have legal
and safe abortion in your state that's
the actual answer if you care so much
but i'll i'll counter with this please
violence doesn't work
in terms of trying to get support for
your cause and win win for your cause
but if you're trying to destabilize the
country to burn it down yeah see what
happens is i've been doing a lot of
reading about bleeding kansas and that's
you know some people are comparing
what's happening now to bleeding kansas
it was basically a statewide civil war
in the territory of kansas just it ended
because the civil war started so it
basically from 1854 until 1861 you had
this period of civil war but in kansas
pro-slavery groups and free staters
fighting and killing each other
john brown who was you know
rose to notoriety uh due to bleeding
kansas sure was angry that abolitionists
were pacifists he didn't care to
persuade anyone he just straight walked
up to slave owners and blasted just
killed him killed five just walked up to
people with his kids started killing
people
he did not care if anyone agreed with
him or not he said i'm done what ends up
happening is this causes an escalation
on the other side
so if your goal is to win for your cause
because you're hoping a stable country
will say
we voted for this and now this rule will
be enacted
that's a terrible idea right this jane's
revenge stuff the only the only thing i
can see is the outcome is going to be
the inverse of what they
presumably want
people on the other side are going to
counter it but that will likely just
lead to destabilization and more
violence yeah i think but the other
issue is right if if you're on the side
what media are you listening to and
watching if you're watching media that
says well this is in reaction to if
that's the media you're hearing
then it sounds like it's almost
reasonable see it's an attack on us so
we're being aggressive to defend against
the bad people who are trying to hurt us
so i'm not sure that it actually turns
their side off if anything it just makes
us to your point it makes both people
both sides dig in harder and it hurts
anywhere in the middle because now if i
say hey
stop the violence the right goes to me
well they're killing us and the left
goes well they'll kill they're killing
us you're a bad guy so now i don't hate
one side or the other so no i'm the bad
guy too it actually is what it wants to
doing is stifling
the calm person the person says can we
can't we you all get along it that
dislike was that person shameless did
you did you yeah so jane's revenge has
taken credit for various firebombings of
wow yeah yes from whatever fbi says
they're investigating yeah the gop has
demanded that they get labeled a
domestic terror organization but i don't
think the federal government actually
labels domestic terror organizations i
don't know if that's a thing you know a
lot of people on the right saying antifa
should be and people on the left saying
like the clan or the right-wing group
should be and the government's like we
don't label groups we label actions like
we have criminal actions or not
i don't see de-escalation coming i've
been saying this for a long time
uh you know in the intro to the show
i pointed out
four years ago five years ago maybe even
three years ago if i went to you and
said in three years time a a far leftist
would attempt to assassinate a sitting
supreme court justice because the court
because for the first time in history a
draft opinion had been leaked showing
that rohi wade roe v wade and planned
parenthood vk was going to be overturned
people were showing him in the streets
firebombing buildings you'd be like no
way you know what though people told me
that was never going to happen the part
of that that would surprise me the most
was the possibility of roe v wade being
overturned
exactly yeah exactly the fact that the
left would react violently is not
something i think that whatever but this
this has to be you know this has to be
slowly ex accepted and it has become
right since the the the recent violence
in the streets right
this has become more acceptable as
normal right if you and i'll give you a
good example uh historical one if it's
say
1912 1913 germany
and if you were to say to someone hey
you know what 30 years from now you
germans will be systematically uh you
know uh rounding up all your jewish
population and murdering them all
they've been like stop we're germany we
would never do that no come on stop yet
30 years later they're doing it and if
you were born if you were born at that
time
if you're a young woman a young man born
in say 1910 1912 in germany you would
have never thought to do such a thing it
would have taken years
for me to be brainwashed enough to do
nothing right to not be involved but
just let it happen and be like well yeah
i guess they kind of deserve it because
they're the bad guys this guy hitler
said and i think we're finding a similar
thing again my point is they're the bad
guys so it's okay remember people who do
bad things always validate their bad
behavior they don't think they're doing
bad things they validate it somehow
exactly right no group of people who
ever took power to oppress another group
throughout all of history said you know
what we want to oppress somebody they go
those people are pressing up us so we
have to stop them and any and all means
which are necessary or therefore
justifiable because they're horrible
people yes and so when you look at this
story there's a really great lesson in
media framing here how did the
independent title this jane's revenge
group appears to threaten violence no no
a terrorist organization which has taken
credit for firebombing pro-life
organizations as well as charities that
are set up to help pregnant women care
for their children
is threatening violence
yes
yo
that's crazy you know i do think that
this is a crazy thing to say but in
wartime terroristic violence does get
people on your side for instance like
the american revolutionaries were
terrorists according to king george
george washington was a terrorist and
henry knox
attacked an armory in i think it was
northern new york early early on um
killed a bunch of british guys stole a
bunch of british artillery took it down
to washington outside boston they sieged
boston they took boston and then the
french joined the americans so like if
if the americans were were losing the
battle the french didn't join because of
that it wasn't but it was a result of
victory after victory and a belief that
maybe the americans could win if the if
the americans weren't
winning if they weren't doing this
terroristic destruction then the french
never would have helped them and they
would have been stomped out but we're
not in war that's a wartime thing this
is not a wartime thing but my problem is
people aren't upset about this
that that that that is my my my central
issue right if you look at say for
example in new york state recently the
buffalo shooting right
everyone's mad about that no one's like
yay everyone's mad about that well
that's what you think whether it's the
guns or the bad guy or the races or
whatever you think you're still not
happy about that
this is like whatevs and that's my point
there are enough people who aren't doing
anything about that when they when they
came after the the judge when they came
after the judge i really thought thought
that this would be a big deal coming
after
a supreme court judge and now we do
nothing about that that is my problem is
is the apathy that's my biggest issue i
don't i i don't think it's apathy and i
don't think people are whatever about
this i think they support it i think the
left is happy about it and i think
they're happy about what's going on in
front of the homes gen seki said we
certainly encourage more of this
when they were showing up illegally in
front of judge's home to try and sway
the court's opinion which is a federal
crime
then a guy who gets the address and
information from these same protesters
shows up to kill a sitting supreme court
justice that guy gets arrested and
charged okay that happened
the protesters come back that same day
and federal government does nothing
and my point is that the the majority of
the country
doesn't self-identify as left or right
like that they just think they're
average people and they lean left or
they lean right
that middle is what we is is the people
who should be angry people should say
look i'm not a hardcore leftist or
writer but i'm angry because this is
unacceptable regardless of my left or
right and that's what i'm saying people
aren't saying that i don't think there's
a middle you don't think so
no i think kind of in the middle here no
there's one guy see we got one no you're
not in the middle you know exactly what
we're talking about you know you know
exactly what's going on but when when
the street violence kicked off in 2020
for instance and they were bombing
buildings and destroying buildings i
wanted trump to send in the national
guard and i was like why day one
national guard but then i started to
question myself am i an authoritarian
for wanting the national guard to come
in that is not the middle
but i mean you have to determine two
factions you go to the average person
and say what do you think about the fire
bombings at pregnancy centers and
they'll go the what yeah yep you go to
other people and they'll say i heard
about that that's crazy we got to stop
that those are the factions
so so the facts are those who aren't
paying attention you're saying i i
usually call it the uninitiated and the
discerning
the people who are inquisitive and
looking into the news trying to
understand what's happening in their
world versus the people who don't have
any don't want anything to do with it i
made a lot of those
so i i uh
most people i think i shouldn't say most
people but a lot of people especially
those who voted for joe biden had no
idea what was going on have no idea what
they're talking about at all
okay so you you go to them and you talk
about with any of this stuff and learn
to go what oh here's a great example
you know look i can respect bill maher
for calling out
entitled millennials and awoke and all
that
but hearing him talk to crystal ball on
his show last friday was laughable she
brought up how
everyone keeps ragging on the mass
printing of money but no one said
anything in 2020 when the fed printed
trillions of dollars to pump into the
stock market to stop it from crashing
right and bill maher goes what are you
talking about yes that oh bill you do
not have the position right now to
challenge your guests after what
happened with dennis prager crystal ball
was right right okay and she's a
progressive and she's right the federal
reserves are printing up money to buy
stocks and assets to bail out the stock
exchange the the markets because there
was a fear was going to tank and that
was bad yep
so bill maher that's his job style stuff
japanese do it all the time you know
what if bill maher watched freedom tunes
he would have known that because he did
a video called corona
right here's a guy who has a show with a
million viewers once a week he does a
what's a once a week show he gets about
a million of the ratings and he doesn't
know what happened
two years ago with major massive fed
bailout spending it's like the biggest
story of the year but but it's it's not
just that it's the hubris that's my
problem
i'm okay if he doesn't know but then why
is he aggressively pushing back he
should go oh did that happen oh let me
look at that
hey can i get a producer on this yeah
get a producer to see if this happened
you know crystal that's a really great
point yes i wish i had known about that
yeah no he was wrong about covington
kids he didn't pay attention to that he
was wrong when dennis prager on his show
said they're putting menstrual tampons
in the men's room he goes no what are
you talking about this is exactly it
bill maher personifies now he may be
coming around right all of a sudden i
like his libertarian streak let's let's
reward the good behavior let's reward
the good behavior absolutely but this is
this is my point i think he is a
barometer
for many of the what you what you'd
probably assume is the middle
if you have people who are blindly
voting for the destruction of the
country and their values and their
economy and everything
i think bill maher represents exactly
why they they watch him they listen to
him sure and he's years behind the curve
in what's going on in this country
so i don't view it as there are
political moderates and they're
extremists i don't view it as far left
far right and middle because well that
makes no sense they call i mean you're
libertarian they call you right wing or
far right or whatever they call me
everything bad they can think of exactly
yes whatever whatever they can call me
they call me right wing and my po my
politics are like centrist liberal
libertarian it doesn't matter you know i
can sit here across from sheamus and we
disagree on on the abortion issue
traditionally as this country did but
we're both far right there's no
distinction among
that group because they don't know what
we're talking about that's the media the
liberal well the liberal economic orders
media apparatus slandering people though
that's not a real
judgment call no i know but it does
become real when they brainwash people
to believe it yeah
that's yes you have people who blindly
believe it and people who don't and
those are the factions there's no middle
there's no there's no person who's like
you know i do believe the narrative but
also not really it's like do you do you
know what's going on in this country or
don't you if someone said joe biden
tried to uh try tried to get a quid pro
quo from the president of ukraine
threatening to withhold u.s uh loan
guarantees in exchange for the firing of
prosecutor quid pro quo and people will
be like we had a guy in the show he goes
that never happened and i was like you
want me to pop the video and i pull up
the video and it's joe biden going like
so i tell him you want the billion
dollars you got to fire the prosecutor
well sob guy gets fired and i'm like did
you not even bother googling this story
you have people you're asking
i'm with you but there's two important
questions i think here number one
if that's true can you actually expect
the average american who's struggling to
survive as a general rule to spend that
much time understanding everything it's
it they become overwhelmed it's
information over it's it's just too much
information it's overloaded i'm not
expecting them to do so they're going to
listen to whatever their talking head
tells them whether it's rachel maddow or
tucker carlson whichever side they pick
or if they're smart temple whoever
whoever's whoever is there whoever is
there they're talking head of the day
and they're going to listen to them and
probably follow that person that's
that's
so that that's an element but i i see it
as
on the right it's the exception on the
left it's the rule on the right you have
post liberals disaffected liberals
moderates libertarians conservatives why
because
the right is a group of people who are
like well i don't think tucker's right
all the time
i'll watch tucker i'll see what brian
stelter and rachel maddow are saying but
i want to know what the truth is you of
course have people who are like i just
turn on tucker and i tune everything out
sure and it's like okay well that's
you're probably better off than if
you're watching rachel maddow and then
you have people who are like whatever
anderson cooper tells me sure
but but
i think you find this you find this
right now with elon musk you found it
with joe rogan i would even say dave
rubin
many of these people were much more left
than right
but they stepped over a bound and some
was some barrier they stepped over and
the left said
not good enough how dare you
and they alienated the person and the
person believed well i can't be left so
what can i be and the right goes here we
are hey hey we love you joe we love you
dave we love you come on over
and they were more accepting it wasn't
that the i don't think it was the person
themselves was actually more
right-leaning but they were accepted by
the right because they felt shunned by
the left but there's no right the right
doesn't mean anything like what's a core
right-wing value right now
freedom of speech maybe if you if you
look at are you saying political are you
talking social when we're talking about
what left and right means colloquially
in cultural politics in in any kind of
politics yeah what is a shared
right-wing value i'd imagine it's free
speech
but hold on
the left historically was was in favor
of freeze
yeah joe rogan is not conservative but
they're calling him right wing now and
it's not that free speech is a
right-wing principle it's that the left
said okay we've now decided if you're
for free speech you are no longer one of
us well yes that was and that's my point
you're right we're we're on the same
page here that's why
they were they were kicked out versus
they were pulled in the right didn't
pull them in they were thrown out by the
left
and accepted by the rest
that's liberal yeah and i would agree
with you on that so we're in sort of a
strange position where what the left has
done culturally is they framed the
narrative such that this very bizarre
new ideology
which a very tiny sliver of the
population believes in is the dominant
view and if you're against that there's
only one other category for you which is
strange because i mean the united states
like developed western nations are
pretty much the only countries where
this ideology or some format exists and
even in those countries it's like maybe
three or four percent of the population
at most who believe it and yet it's been
framed such that there's that view and
then there's everyone else's view even
though almost no one in the world
actually believes in this and so it is a
problem you ask the question what do
conservatives actually believe i think
today because we have this framing and
everyone who's outside of that far
fringe on the left is conservative it
doesn't mean anything other than you're
not in this tiny group yes to me and i'm
conservative what i've understood that
to mean
is basically pro-family um you are in
favor of tradition in many aspects of
culture
you you believe marriage is between a
man and a woman um you i guess it
depends on how far back you want to go
with respect to what was considered
acceptable in our culture but i think
that's at the heart of it when i hear
that there are people who are pro-choice
being called conservative it's not just
me as a purist saying i don't want those
people my movement it's just me
recognizing definitions have meanings
how can you be how can you be like in
favor of like homosexual behavior or
abortion and be conservative i don't
understand like that doesn't fit that's
not what the word means we had a
progressive on this show
and sheamus mostly stated the
conversation and it was pro-abortion
versus pro-choice and the progressive
view was that i was far right for being
pro-choice
it's the weirdest yeah nonsense yeah
i've seen a lot of my friends in new
york city as they've gotten older who
were democrats for years just
for a year parents were democrats
they're democrats and now they can't
find a home because they've been told
that well all republicans are evil so i
can't vote for republican i've been told
for 20 years the republicans are evil so
i can't vote for them right so but i
can't vote democrats i don't believe in
them anymore so they're checking out
now i'm trying to go to the libertarian
party obviously lp.org by the way lp.org
if you're in new york state lpny.org
by the way i'm going to get them to go
libertarian but it's very hard because
they've been taught this this there's
two sides exactly there's only two sides
do everything we say or not which is why
you see so many people
are afraid to say the wrong thing
if you say the wrong thing they throw
you out of the tribe and you have to go
to the tribe
you but because in their minds there's
only two tribes the tribe i've been told
is evil for 20 years
and the tribe i'm in now if i said the
wrong thing i have to go with the evil
people that i've been told for 20 years
or evil and it becomes a problem i think
comcast bought msnbc in 2013. right when
all this weird stuff started happening
and then they started telling everyone
these other people are enemies focused
stay inside of our grip and then so
they're starting to think those other
people are enemies and then everyone
else that's looking at these people that
are now being engaged in this cult
have a choice to make am i going to be
conscientious with these with these
people am i going to be considerate and
not take it personally or they're
calling me a villain am i going to just
strike back and and so a lot you still
you do see people going at it but yes a
lot of people aren't and those people
are still considered on the outside of
this media that's why they hate the
whole idea of politics right i'm out
here campaigning right and i'm meeting
people and i find people who very often
do one of two things when i talk to them
they literally do not want to talk to me
like i can't deal with this nothing to
your point that totally checked out
right you would say tim i'm checked out
i don't want to talk to you i can't
handle this or the other one they give
me some type of test
to see if i fit in one side or the other
they'll ask me a question it's a test
okay are you going to say this you're
going to say that they'll say things
where you think about kids in school
learning by drag queens they'll ask that
question right and then if i answer the
wrong way then okay well i'm the
opposite guy i'm the bad guy whatever
they want right they do that all the
time it's very challenging because i'm
trying to give them an answer right i'm
trying to show them away and those are
the people who i begin to turn the
people who are interested
interested but actually feel like the
team i'm i was on sucks the team i'm on
now i'm not happy with and that's the
people who i get to turn that group of
people
the other side sucks decide i'm on now
not so good either thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there